>> Tucker: IT'S NOT THAT
EASY BEING CREEPY PORN
LAWYER.
LEGAL PROBLEM.
LIKELY HEAD TO THE BIG HOUSE
FOR EXTORTION.
RELATIVELY SPEAKING THAT'S
NOT THE BIGGEST PROBLEM.
THE BIGGER PROBLEM FOR CPL
NOBODY REMEMBERS HIM.
ALL TIME CHAMPION ON
JEOPARDY WAS ASKED TO NAME
THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER AND
HE COULDN'T DO IT.
WATCH.
THIS THIS LAWYER'S STAR ROSE
WHILE REPPING STORMY DANIELS
BUT FELL AFTER HE WAS
ACCUSED OF TRYING TO EXTORT
MILLIONS FROM MIKEY
MILLIONS FROM NIKEY
MILLIONS FROM NIKE IN 2019.
[BUZZER]
HIS NAME QUICKLY FORGOTTEN.
ALEX TREBEK WASN'T EXACTLY
PRECISELY RIGHT.
IT'S NOT THAT HIS NAME IS
FORGOTTEN.
IT'S THAT PEOPLE NEVER KNEW
HIS NAME IN THE FIRST PLACE.
JEOPARDY WANTED SOME OBSCURE
OTHER NAME FOR THE CREEPY
PORN LAWYER BUT IF YOU WATCH
THIS SHOW YOU KNOW HE GOES
BY ONLY ONE TITLE.
SO WHO IS THIS CREEPY PORN
LAWYER.
>> WELL THE WORLD'S
CREEPIEST PORN LAWYER HAS
GOTTEN FAMOUS.
WE MENTIONED THE CREEPY PORN
LAWYER YOU HAVE HEARD ABOUT.
THE ONE YOU HAVE SEEN ON TV
THREATENING PEOPLE.
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD HUSBAND
COVER THE CREEPY PORN
LAWYER.
IT'S ALL ABOUT THE CREEPY
PORN LAWYER.
#CREEPY PORN LAWYER.
>> PLEASE STICK AROUND THE
CREEPY PORN LAWYER IS BACK.
THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER IS
BACK.
THAT'S THE BAD NEWS.
PICTURE YOURSELF STANDING IN
KITCHEN AT NIGHT AND GETTING
ONE LAST GLASS OF WATER OUT
IN THE BACKYARD IS THE